yeah from uh San Gabriel California uh
the city of San Gabriel and the second
row Valley that's just east of Los
Angeles
um
I grew up in the neighborhood over there
uh you know I my I guess my story
actually starts with my parents
um you know my dad was a Pachuco
gangster from Maravilla and uh my mom
was living in Boyle Heights uh
with the Immigrant family she was they
were Jews so uh
a lot of Jews that had immigrated here
from Europe
settled in Boyle Heights and they had an
uneasy relationship with the Hispanics
there
they didn't get along you know and uh
what the Jews really hated was when
their daughters would end up going with
these Suave Pachuco guys
which that was my dad and my mom and uh
you know so
and uh she ended up you know uh
you know taking on the culture the
Chicano culture uh both my parents went
to prison
um my mom shot and killed a girl and my
dad went for a string of robberies
and my sister and I grew up in foster
care
and we ended up in a foster home in uh
in San Gabriel and you know we were you
know Mexican kids and this was a white
foster home that you know they got
foster parents of the year for taking in
you know a Hispanic kids you know like a
but um it turned out to be quite an
abusive uh
situation for my sister and I and uh
you know it was kind of like they were
um
gonna beat the Mexican out of us you
know like Mexicans were bad and they
were going to take these Mexican kids
and teach them how to live and how to be
white you know and
I rebelled I rebelled and I I had to
when I was around 11 or 12 I felt lost I
didn't know who I was you know my foster
dad would get drunk and he'd go come in
the room and say you dirty rotten filthy
Mexican you know like and it was a bad
situation my foster mom was very violent
and would just beat the living [__] out
of us
um
so I had to find my
my purpose my people you know and I knew
I was Mexican and you know and uh
even though I live in a white
neighborhood the Mexican neighborhood in
San Gabriel was not far and I went to
school with those guys and uh I just ran
away from that foster home started
living over there in the neighborhood
you know and and learning the ways of uh
I knew were my people and uh you know I
joined the Barrio or you know the Gang
and uh
I I felt like I had to just immerse
myself in that you know like
that meant everything in the world to me
all I gave is [__] about was my Barrio
And My Gang and my homeboys and the
conflict that we had going and the style
you know I just like it just became so
much a part of me
um
that that's all I cared about in my life
and um you know my my father and my
uncles were all prison artists and
prison tattoos and you know so I I had
some art ability you know and and um
you know I love the Chicano culture all
the
you know the uh artistic elements you
know that were associated with uh our
our subculture our Chicano gangster
culture you know like all the Mexican
revolutionary type are all the religious
art you know because we were Catholics
um you know the vario the writing you
know like you know you when you're from
ovario you want to say something about
who you are you know I'm coyote you know
and where are you from you know I'm from
sangra you know and
so uh at the young age you know and you
know coincidentally my
you know uh some great prison tattoo
artists were from my Barrio you know my
older homeboy Tarzan and uh little man
and those guys came out of prison and
they taught me how to you know do hand
poke tattoos and so
I became the tattoo guy for all my
little homies in fact I still have some
of my tattoos you know from when I was
12 years old 13 years old you know and
so I became the vario tattooer uh
when I first you know fell in love with
the culture and you know the tattoos I
remember I was uh I got arrested for
running away from home
uh from the foster home
and I was uh just 12 years old
just learning about you know being a
cholo and everything and uh so I was in
juvenile hall and they put me in a
holding tank because they were going to
release me and let me go home so I was
in this holding tank by myself
and they brought this older kid you know
he was like 17 or something like that
and I probably would have never gave me
the time of day because you know I was
just a little punk you know and he came
in and he was all badass and cholo Don
he had tattoos all over you know and I
was like oh my God you know this guy was
like Superman to me I was like wow you
know so I started asking him about the
tattoos and he goes yeah yeah this is my
Mario Lopez Maravilla and you know my
homeboy from prison did this and did
that and I was like how did they do it
and he's like oh you know you just get a
a a
needle and wrap thread around it and
melted into a toothbrush and uh put a
little bit of glue on the thread and
then just dip it in India ink and you
know and just poke it in
and uh so I was just like yeah yeah yeah
okay and I remember he told me uh he
goes you know uh mascara works too you
know like girls mascara so
I got out that night and uh I was in my
bed and I pitched me a little tent you
know my blankets and had flashlights I
got my sister's mascara I made that
needle and I did my first little tattoo
right here I was gonna write my name but
uh you know that turned out to be too
much for me but I was 12 years old and
this whole arm was uh covered with hand
folk stuff that I did on myself
and I remember the uh my foster parents
thought I was crazy you know and and
I had to go to a psychologist and I you
know something about that I remember you
know the psychologist was like now you
can trust me you can talk to me you
could tell me whatever you know I'm not
gonna tell your parents you know and I
told him everything you know smoking
cigarettes ditching school all that
stuff and he told him everything and
they beat the living [__] out of me and
just and I ran away again so
but you know uh I think that was
part of the contribution of me you know
not trusting Authority or
or adults or people
anyways uh
I went on to uh live a pretty crazy wild
lifestyle
in Navarro but most of all I became you
know institutionalized
um
I didn't care about nothing
it was La Vida Loca for me you know life
is crazy and uh and no fear nothing I
had no carers in the world I did
whatever I robbed you know I picked up
that gun I shot people I was involved in
this you know
uh crazy gang war between Lomas and
sangra
and I was totally immersed in that
and uh
so consequently I spent a lot of time in
institutions in in fact I mean from the
time I was uh
12 years old
to I finally went to uh youth 30 when I
was uh 17 but from the time of uh 12
years old till I was 17 the longest
period of time that I ever stayed out at
once was like two months you know I
would get out and I'd get right back
to work you know and uh stealing and
robbing
shooting getting arrested but all the
while drawing and doing my tattoos on
homies you know so
finally when I went to Youth Authority
uh
you know um
I was in a Preston School of Industry
uh funny story you know like
so they we used to be able to use the
pay phones I mean this is in the 70s you
know to uh call home and stuff and uh so
the institution was up in this little
town called ion and the telephone
operators
in that area knew when they were picking
up coins from the guys in that in the in
the y a you know so I met up and they
talked to us so I met a telephone
operator and you know uh
some of one of the guys that lived up
there I had her meet somebody and then
she started smuggling or bringing me
weed and you know and so in the visiting
I go in my with my radio and uh I'd
unscrew it with a filing you know like a
fingernail clipper stuff the weed in
there and then screw it back up and then
roll little joints and not too many
people were good at smuggling dope in
there but everybody's smuggled money so
I was making a ton of money selling
these joints and and then we figure out
a way to have pounds of weed mailed into
there through the drug program
ironically because you know the drug
program their method was to break the
guys down you know like kind of
humiliate them and make them wear signs
and say I'm stupid and and then uh and
then build them back up and then finally
they would build them at back up to a
point where they would give them
Authority you know so
two of the guys that searched the
packages were homeboys of my other
friend and so I worked in the gym and
the drug program was right there and
then the pounds would come in those guys
would let it come in and I'd sneak over
there you know like to the window and we
ended up with like
pounds of weed inside a institution of
only like 400 people so there was weed
everywhere you know and and these uh
they wanted to find out who was behind
it they got to get this guy you know
like they didn't they didn't suspect me
or my girlfriend at all to them you know
they I heard one of their staff say oh
no she's she is a good girl you know and
uh she's she's a phone operator if she
even knew that he smoked weed she
wouldn't even come up here and visit
them so I was off the list for a minute
but you know finally somebody snitched
on me and uh and
and uh they closed the gym so this was
their way of getting me so they closed
the gym and said it was going to be
closed for two weeks and I had weed in
there and so I was like oh man so I
talked to her on the phone I told her
you know what come up Saturday don't
bring anything because I knew that way
it was getting kind of hot
and I go just bring some on Sunday
so Saturday everything was okay and she
came in the next day she brought me the
weed I put it in my radio and then the
staff were like
you know uh Mr negretti would you and
your visit come and they go we heard you
have weed in this radio and I was like
oh man you know and uh they opened it up
they found the reason that guy was so
mad he got the radio bam smashed it on
the floor you [__] and he tells
her you get out of here you know because
you know she's looking at a felony you
know what I mean but to them you know
like and I did I I I I
uh
deceived her you know
seduced her right I made her do this you
know illegal thing for me you know
uh they gave me um
three more years to my time in a program
called Tamarack and what Tamarack was
was like
a lock-up unit
for criminally insane Youth Authority
kids you know and the what you'd have to
do so first they send you to Tracy
Prison and you'd be in a lock up in
Tracy Prison and and uh so you're on a
floor and you're locked up but you can
hear all the older guys you know talking
to us and they'd be schooling us and
telling us prison politics and how to
run [__] and why you know and uh and
then after you did your 90 days there
they take you back to tamarack and uh
you know because Preston is a real old
institution uh there's a big castle
there which was the very first Y.A but
down in this Gully was like this lockup
program built of old Granite bricks with
big iron doors and I mean it looked like
a dungeon it was the most awesome
looking place you that you'd ever see it
was like a dungeon out of a movie and uh
that that program was uh was wild so at
the time the staff their their way of
dealing with this is these guys are all
hopeless cases you know just we'll make
a deal with you guys you don't kill each
other
and we'll bring you magazines uh we'll
bring you ink we'll bring you needles
we'll bring you stuff to do your tattoos
and uh we had gotten the plans how to
make a tattoo machine from uh Susanville
prison and uh so we started making
tattoo machines and they were just
letting us tattoo so we're all covered
with tattoos and you know what
um I I wouldn't have became a tattoo
artist at all if it wasn't for that
program that Tamarack program that let
us do tattoos and in fact I got so good
at it because every day we tattooed for
two and a half years straight just
tattooing every day that even some of
those staff guys thus you know the uh
the guards
I even tattooed some of them
so
you know and um I I got really good at
tattooing and I remember I used to tell
the staff you know what I still had
another year or so to go a year and a
half I still had to go and um
I remember I was uh I would always tell
the staff you guys just sent me to board
you know like just send me the board and
give me a time cut let me go home you
know I'll get a job as a tattoo artist
you know and uh
and all of a sudden one day they go
Freddy uh negrady get up you're going to
board and I was like what and they're
like get the limos ready and I'll go
what are these guys talking about you
know and um I went to board and they
were saying well the staff say that you
have made the best Improvement that
they've ever seen in in this facility
and that you're a great artist and
they're sure that you'll be able to find
some career in the art world you know
they understand about tattooing
and I got you know I got a Time cut and
uh immediately when I got out the first
thing I did you know in the the phone
operator and my sister together they got
got me an apartment you know and
but the first thing I did was set up
shop you know I had my homemade tattoo
machines and I started tattooing my
homeboys I started tattooing people the
neighbors because I lived in Pico Rivera
next thing you know I had a big old line
of people that wanted to get tattooed
meanwhile
Jack Rudy and Good Time Charlie had
opened up a tattoo shop in East L.A so
the style of tattooing that I was doing
was prison style but with Chicano themes
you know like clown girls and smile and
I'll cry later roses and religious stuff
you know like all those images that I
was talking about that
Jeremiah youth that I love so much that
represented my culture you know Aztec
art you know and um
so when I uh
uh when I heard about this tattoo shop
that opened in East L.A some of those
guys were showing me the work you know
and uh I was like oh my God man these
guys are good they're doing prison style
tattoos you know and uh and it looked
like really really good you know and I
was tripping out because I knew that you
know I I got shop tattoos when I was a
kid and stuff and I had seen nothing
like that the only kind of style of
tattooing any tattoo shop anywhere was
traditional tattoos which are kind of
like simple cartoon looking you know
with color and um
these guys were doing
black and gray tattoos that that looked
like they were done in prison
and it was right in East L.A right in
the heart of that Chicano cholo culture
you know
so
I said it started sending my guys people
that I was tattooing over there I was
like you know go over there and uh you
know show them this you know
and uh so right away they saw the work
that I was doing and uh Jack Rudy uh
who's a really good friend of mine of
course but we're like brothers
but he saw the work I was doing you know
and uh invited me to go to the tattoo
shop
and so
you know and I went to the shop it was
funny because the first thing I saw were
some of my designs on the wall you know
some of my drawings from prison you know
and uh
I was like hey I drew that man and he's
like yeah that's what everybody says man
that their cousin or their uncle or
somebody in prison drew that you know
and I was like no I drew it and I showed
them the the original artwork you know
and um
you know a Side Story from that
you know is when I was in Youth
Authority before I went to lock up I
worked in the print shop and so we used
to make stationary paper in the print
shop
you know for the guys to ride home on so
I draw a design and then reduce it put
it on the stationary and then we would
take stacks of that stationary paper and
mail it to all the prisons and so that
design that I drew became like
uh it doubled as a tattoo pattern you
know
so anyways uh so when Jack saw that
um you know him and I hit it up real
good uh Good Time Charlie at the time
was the owner of the shop
um I don't think they they did they
weren't that interested
in you know in me or you know because uh
you know I guess most gangsters you know
at the time they're not the easiest to
work with you know and a lot of them are
drug addicts you know I remember Jack
took a good look at my arms he goes let
me see your tattoos he's looking that up
and my veins make sure I wasn't a hype
but
so anyways me and Jack said oh well just
keep in touch and I went back to doing
what I was doing and
but not long after that Good Time
Charlie who's the owner of that tattoo
shop
he uh found religion became a Christian
and felt that he should quit tattooing
and so uh
when he did he sold the shop to Ed Hardy
and a lot of people know about Ed Hardy
because the clothing line Ed Hardy by
Christianity but that was Ed Hardy's
work Ed Hardy was like
the pope of tattooing he was like the
man he went to Japan and you know and
studied and learned the Japanese style
he introduced that Japanese style to
America
he uh he
um
he was the first one to do a appointment
only tattoo shop the first one to start
tattooing celebrity clientele
he just uh the first one to do
Publications show you know making books
showing people the world of tattoos he
did more for tattooing than anybody and
when he saw the black and gray work that
was being done to him it was this
amazing new style it's like wow where
did this come from you know and um and
he was so into this new style that he
didn't want that tattoo shop to fall in
the wrong hands so he bought that tattoo
shop and then uh Jack Rudy told him
about me and Ed said we got to hire this
guy man that's we got to get this guy
Freddy over here to work
and so together
myself Jack Rudy Ed Hardy Bob Roberts
then not long after Mark Mahoney Mike
Brown you know uh Kate helenbrandt we
were the ones that introduced this new
style of tattooing to the tattoo World
which is today known as black and gray
realism and um
you know at the time I I think I
realized that you know we were doing
something special you know um
I never saw myself
as anything that special you know like I
learned how to do this in prison I was a
gangster I was never a nice guy I was
never a good guy you know
but uh now I found myself being one of
the founding fathers of
This Global phenomenon of uh black and
gray tattooing
so we went on you know uh to uh
do this new style of tattooing you know
and
and uh it was really amazing Ed Hardy he
helped me you know I remember the first
time I met Ed Hardy uh Jack was on me
okay Ed Hardy's gonna come because our
shop was in East L.A and Ed Hardy was in
San Francisco and
um
so you know I was all excited I'm gonna
meet my
you know the boss you know and I heard
so much about him you know we didn't
have social media or nothing like that
there's a there was no way to see his
work and when I asked Jack you know so
what kind of work does he do is just
like I just a color [__] you know like
oh all right
um
Jack didn't like color that much you
know well neither did I we were both
very much into
you know what we were doing black and
gray and we detested the color you know
so anyways when uh Ed Hardy came down he
came down with Bob Roberts and uh
we closed the shop
and uh I remember Ed Hardy was looking
at my photo album back then we used a
Polaroid to take pictures of our tattoos
so he's going man this worked man is so
good you know and he's not here I
brought some pictures of mine check out
mine
and then I it just blew me away because
it was just like bad piece after back
piece
full body coverage just like and
Japanese tattoos like I never saw
Japanese tattoos before I was so uh
mesmerized by the fact that
you know the way we did tattoos like one
here one there like little badges you
know and that style has gotten popular
again but you know and then maybe fill
in the spaces
but
this was like uh the whole body was a
canvas with one flowing picture you know
yeah and I I looked at Jack like just
color [__] Jack you know what I mean
like man this was really something you
know and and uh I was totally amazed
that's funny that night you know I want
you want to give a good impression you
know to to your boss and just the first
time I met him and uh
then some of my homeboys from uh Compton
and Little Valley right here in UCLA
they came to the shop you know and I was
like oh but these guys are my tights you
know and I was in in jail with them all
my life and just like you know we're
good so I wanted Ed Hardy to meet him
you know because I did so much work on
them all you know so I let him in the
shop and Ed Hardy was looking at all the
work and we're all talking then all of a
sudden Bam Bam Bam Bam you know somebody
starts pounding at the front door you
know these these three guys uh is that
two young cholo guys and I guess their
dad
and then I I opened the door he we had a
you know a barred gate
and I opened the door and I go uh we're
close and he's like ah rattling the gate
nah you open up right now I'm gonna have
you you're gonna cover up this stupid
gang [__] on him and he's yelling at me
I'm gonna look dude right now you know
we're closed I'm not gonna you know
tattoo but if you come back you know
tomorrow I'll take care of it for you no
problem and he he insisted he even tried
to grab me and I was like dude come on
man you know like
so then uh
as I'm arguing with this guy Ed Hardy
and and um and Bob Roberts they're just
like what the hell's going on
Meanwhile my gangster friends went out
the back door and as I'm talking to this
guy here they come from behind him
saying Freddie said the shop is closed
and start stabbing the [__] out of them
and uh oh man and and then they I know
it's not funny but man that was bizarre
Ed Hardy it hit the ceiling those guys I
was like dude get the hell out of here
and that kid's like hearing his neck is
bleeding he's like you did this yeah
this is your fault I'm like hey man I
no you did this
anyways uh
so that was my first impression that I
gave to my boss uh
anyways
um we went on to do uh some great things
you know like I remember at the uh fifth
world tattoo convention
um you know I had learned from Ed you
know like
you know prior to that I would go to San
Francisco I wanted to learn about colors
I started adding color I was doing black
and gray with little bits of color in it
you know um I was just trying to do more
and be more with with my art you know
and I remember I did and doing bigger
you know I started seeing the whole body
as a canvas like that you know so I was
always pushing these guys to do a whole
back piece you know and I remember I did
this one back piece on this guy and it
was like a virgin Mary you know her
hands are out and uh
she's all in black and gray but in the
background are colored roses and then at
the top were these two angels with like
a little bubble and a baby in the bubble
supposedly uh baby Jesus and then off
her hands were these rays and on one
side was in between was a girl's face a
beautiful girl's face and the planet
Earth you know all in color on the other
side was a fiery skull and the plant I
mean uh and the planet Earth on fire you
know so it I was kind of like saying you
know like
Heaven and Hell or life and death or
with this tattoo and
and so and that was uh 1980 and uh you
know I remember I won tattoo artist of
the year with that tattoo and
it was just uh those were really amazing
times and we really you know took
elevated tattooing our thing and Ed's
thing and Mining Jacks yes we wanted to
promote our prison style gangster style
cholo style tattooing
uh Chicano style you know black and gray
realism
but what we were really trying to do was
to elevate Tattooing in the eyes of
people
to be seen as an art form
you know because people would look at
tattoos and say well it's not an art you
know tattooing is not an art they
actually hated it you know a lot of
people
you know hated tattooing
uh and there was a literal argument
as to whether or not tattooing was an
art and uh our thing was we're trying to
elevate tattooing to the point where
it's considered a form of art like
airbrushing or
painting on canvas are pen and ink you
know it's just our canvas is the human
body and you know and our our brushes
our tattoo machines and our our paints
our inks you know so
um
I
people detest it I remember I went in
the store and I was in Beverly Hills for
something
and the lady was like
she's looking at me I had a tank top on
it she goes oh my God why did you do
that to yourself oh this she goes and
you're you're so nice looking oh you
know like for her you know I ruined my
life but you know something I always
realized I felt like you know what
there's a big future in tattooing
because I remember I would go to
Disneyland and I I was proud of all my
tattoos and I'd wear a tank top people
were like whoa this guy is kind of
threatening looking you know with all
these tattoos but the kids man the kids
would be like Mommy Daddy look at the
tattoo man you know can I see your
tattoos and stuff and they'd be all
around me and the parents would be like
come on Johnny you know like I'm so
sorry they just you know like no no no
it's okay I know the kids love tattoos
you know so that's when I knew that uh
at least there's a future in tattooing
because if the kids love it when they're
adults they're gonna of it you know so
and I was right you know
um and I'm glad to have uh be old enough
to live through that because what I've
seen take place with the art of
tattooing has been just phenomenal just
when you think uh you know it couldn't
get any better some new artist comes
along
and blows everybody out of the water you
know our new style comes along or
whatever
and it's not just here it's globally you
know it's Russia Ukraine it's Japan
Milan Italy Europe Australia
you know uh
Polynesia just
everywhere you know and uh
it's kind of like creating this uh
community of people you know it's like
uh
tattooed people you know the people that
are really in it you know and
um
so
I think
you know people would come and ask me
well what do you think you know like uh
of these TV shows you know it's gonna
burn tattooing out or you know like it's
going to be one of those things where it
gets so popular or it becomes lame you
know
um
and uh
and I I thought about that you know
you know it's like are these TV shows
and all this publicity and everybody
getting tattooed and it becoming you
know like so normalized that
that it's gonna become like unpopular
you know like
and uh
and I haven't seen it and I don't see it
and the reason why is because number one
that [__] hurts
and uh you're not going to be a wuss and
sit down and get tattooed it's a
commitment
that takes enduring pain
and so that puts it at this category of
Mystique type category and the imagery
um
although people are doing whatever image
images they want to do
the imagery still is you know like kind
of at a Darkness level you know skulls
you know dragons you know that that kind
of thing you know like and that kind of
imagery never becomes unpopular what's
the subcultures you know
so
I see tattooing as just becoming even
more popular
so anyways uh
that's where we are with the tattooing
and uh you know that's my contribution
um I'm happy with uh how my life turned
out
although
um I've really went through some rough
times you know um
on a you know personal level uh
you know after I was tattooing so long
and you know I got married and you know
I had a son you know and uh
and
I don't know at the time
you know when I was a gang banger I was
mostly into you know the violent aspect
of it I was mostly you know gang banging
you know I never was you know yeah I
drank and all that stuff smoke weed but
it's never really into hard drugs you
know like cocaine and heroin any of that
stuff but
I don't know why I
uh found an interest in it you know so
much later on in my life but
I almost when I used I mean I would look
at my life and say you know this is
amazing I never expected myself to be
any more than
a gangster uh and in prison
perhaps for life you know
um that's what I fully expected to
accomplish in my life and I didn't care
now everything was different
you know because of this opportunity of
tattooing I didn't have to Rob and steal
anymore and it was something that I
loved so much that I was able to put it
first
you know and uh often I wasn't
interested in gang banging or any of
that then I thought you know I need a
family I need to you know
to you know live this normal life and
not I got married and you know I have my
son
but I don't know why I felt
when I got high on heroin
it felt like it added you know it's just
like yeah everything is going so good
what can make it even better a little
bit of heroin yeah now everything's
really good and uh you know so
then I had these uh
troubles you know with the addiction
that uh was breaking up my family uh
getting arrested
you know
uh all these different things you know
uh troubles that were coming in my life
and I remember Jack Rudy and Ed Hardy
they tried everything to try to help me
but
you know unless you experience drug
addiction yourself in some way you'll
never know what a powerful uh you know
um
you know grit you know like they say a
monkey on your back it's just uh it's
impossible it seems impossible and uh
so at the time you know um
I was really down my wife had left me I
was still tattooing and everything but I
didn't care much about my art I just
cared about my addiction I just cared
about getting high I wanted to do that
next tattoo so I can get my next shot
heroin and then uh I remember all of a
sudden these uh
some of the hardcore gangsters that I
knew
uh where were they from
one was from Rancho San Pedro
uh
you know uh ochentas
and
it was odd to even see them together but
they came to the tattoo shop and they
were dressed all nice you know and these
guys were Killers I knew him you know I
did time with them you know and it's
like uh
and they had Bibles in their hands you
know and I was like
what's going on you know like and uh
they started you know uh preaching to me
about Jesus you know uh how you know God
could change your life and you can
overcome your addiction and
things could change for you and all that
and uh you know I went to church with
these guys and uh and I did I I had this
uh spiritual experience and and um I I
overcame my addiction and um
you know the I gotta admit there was
some kind of power there some kind of
you know change in my life and you know
my wife was talking to me again and you
know I got involved with this church
uh that was really well known
for reaching out you know to gang
members it's a Victory Outreach and they
laid the most difficult thing on me you
know like I met the pastor everybody's
like oh this uh guy he's uh famous for
the tattoo his in the tattoo world and
all this stuff and and the pastor and
the church leaders they sat me down
there like
um
tattooing is a sin and uh
and you're gonna have to quit tattooing
you can't continue to tattoo look what
it says right here you know that it's a
sin and uh so you either you know uh
quit tattooing
or you know you're you're not going to
be a Christian you know one or the other
and man oh this
you know tattooing the thing I love I
don't know anything else what else am I
supposed to do you know
and you know and I kind of reiterated
that to them you know like that's all I
know you know I don't know anything else
and they go we love your artwork
you're a great artist
and you could come and work for the
church full time
and I you know I thought about it well
yeah you know I need to support my
family I was back with my wife now and
and um
so I quit tattooing and man
my tattoo colleagues were really really
upset
they were really really upset I mean I
remember Ed Hardy even came and searched
I don't know how but he found me at this
church
and uh he's going to we're all having
these uh these issues with drugs you
know his was cocaine he goes and I
understand you know because it's a
spiritual aspect that helps us to quit
but anyways
so
so I quit tattooing and I went to work
for this church I thought I was going to
work for them and I remember they had a
printing printing press in the in their
basement and uh
you know that was my trade when I was in
Youth Authority was uh was printing so I
went down there and I fixed that that
printing press I got it running I got
all the equipment you know all the
supplies they needed and I started doing
artwork and printing posters and you
know like little religious tracks and I
was doing all this work for them I was
in this basement and uh you know two
months had went by and I was like yeah I
gotta you know I asked you know uh
you know I I gotta when am I gonna get
paid or how I don't I don't want to be
rude and not greedy or anything but so I
asked one of the elders hey you know the
the Pastor said that
I was going to get paid you know this is
a full-time job
and he goes oh yeah yeah okay uh let me
arrange a meeting so he made a meeting
and I went in there and then the pastor
tells me yeah okay so what we're gonna
do is uh get to a cedar slot
slot was back in the days it was
government money that was going to
troubled neighborhoods inner city
neighborhoods and the money was going to
youth centers churches anywhere that
could employ young kids that were in
trouble you know so it was a good
program it was a great program
and um
so I was thinking to see the slot I know
that that's only for three months and
there's a lot of not a lot of money you
know like
I was like well all right okay so I had
to fill out the papers
so when I filled out the papers I didn't
qualify
because I lived in San Gabriel I lived
in a pretty nice area with my
mother-in-law and um
and so the pastor called me back in he
goes you gotta refill out the papers and
put this address you know and I was like
well that's not my address
he's going yeah but you have to live in
a poor neighborhood in order to get this
money
now you want me to lie on this
you know paper to the government
you know
that really pissed me off you know
because these guys told me that
tattooing is a sin I didn't see it
anywhere that didn't come you know that
passage they showed me didn't convince
me I was just taking their word for it
you're telling me the tattoos of sin I
don't really know and now
you know you're telling me to lie and I
know that you know that's one of the Ten
Commandments you know shall not lie and
to the government you know and uh
and we got a big argument right there
and I I walked out of that church and
now I quit tattooing
I I
you know um
I felt kind of lost in the world
and um you know I talked to this other
guy
that was working for not such a you know
like uh fundamentalist group you know
it's called youth guidance Youth for
Christ and he's going what you need to
do is go to college you know and because
of your situation so
I went and I enrolled in college and for
the next six years you know I got a
degree and the reason I I said yeah you
know I I need to go to college I wanted
to go to the Bible College so that
I could study things on my own you know
like uh
I want to know what the word says you
know I want to learn Greek and read it
out of the original Greek you know I
don't want some church or some religious
group telling me what I have to do
what's right what's wrong no I want to
make those decisions for myself
so I went to college and
but not long after I finished College I
you know I got a degree in biblical
literature and also art and uh and then
I got a master's degree in apocalyptic
literature I was real interested in end
of the world type stuff you know so
but then I remember
you know after I got out of college I
always stayed in touch with Jack Rudy
and I remember uh he was like
dude you got to come back to tattooing
he goes you wouldn't believe it you're
like this uh Legend you know that
disappeared from tattooing you know and
everybody wants to you know imitate your
work you got to come back
and I was you know nothing was holding
me from coming back and I
I decided to come back to tattooing you
know after 10 years being away and uh
you know uh same thing you know things
worked out really good I went to work
for Jack in San Diego uh you know I
started doing tattoo shows
um you know everybody loved me you know
they all of a sudden I was like uh one
of the founding fathers of this you know
black and gray tattooing
tattooing had just Advanced by Leaps and
Bounds you know and you know I really
loved it because
um you know back in the day when I went
to work for Ed Hardy and Jack Rudy
I was the only Chicano guy the only
Chicano tattoo artist
especially let alone a cholo you know
and the whole industry and now with this
black and gray and everybody being open
you know like
all of a sudden these floodgates opened
up for my people you know like because
uh Chicanos were so talented and they
knew the art so good now they could you
know uh
find a career own a business you know
it's like it was just an amazing thing
that was happening you know and you know
and I got remarried and all that and I
had another son
um
you know um
but and then I went to Santa Barbara and
I opened up my own tattoo shop there
um you know things were just really
going good
but here came my good old friend you
know like
just like hey you want me to make things
better for you you know did you forget
about me and uh you know I started using
heroin again
and you know because of that you know
like
oh man my life was like this failure
lose everything get back on top drug
addiction the you know like
because I'm 66 years old so I could
probably tell stories to work till next
month here you know but you know this is
what was happening and um
you know uh finally you know I uh
I realized you know um
that
you know maybe you know you can support
your habit and a job like tattoo and you
get paid every day you know you you do
the job and they pay you the cash you
know so it's kind of easy to you know
keep a habit going you know and and um
you know the back then they had the
there was things you know like a loss of
family uh burn Bridges uh loss of
Freedom going to jail you know and those
things will get you you know and it make
you say you know I gotta change I gotta
you know I gotta get myself together
but if those things don't get you and
your health will
because
these drugs are deadly and uh that's
what happened to me all of a sudden I
found that I had a severe heart
condition
um
it was uh
um they called it drug induced
congestive heart failure you know
because I wasn't a big old guy you know
I was a skinny guy but my heart had
enlarged so so big that it was nearly
coming out of the cavity
and you know when your heart enlarges
you know it becomes less
uh
productive as a pump you know and um
you're not getting the oxygen Austin I
couldn't breathe you know
and uh
you know so you know I ended up having
to go to the hospital to the doctor
taking these meds and stuff like that
I got a little bit better but I started
using heroin again
that's the thing about severe addiction
you know it's just like
a hardcore drug addict will look death
in the face and
and laugh you know and uh
and that's what I was doing you know
like
I knew that this drug was killing me and
I just I wouldn't stop I just wouldn't
stop and finally I got arrested you know
um
for possession which was still a felony
anyways so when I went to jail this time
I had already stopped taking my meds I
was already feeling sick again but I
kept using but now I was in jail in the
County Jail uh with you know withdrawing
from heroin and having that heart
problem
and I nearly died I nearly died I got so
skinny I couldn't eat I was in a
wheelchair and all these cops that that
work in there you know that I I tattooed
them all so they all knew me I was
famous with the sheriffs in there you
know they put me in a special dorm to
try to take care of me and they brought
me food and stuff like that and then
I had a heart attack
you know and um
and then you know I went to the hospital
I was there for three weeks they brought
me back to to the jail and a few few
days later I had another attack but it
was some different kind of attack but it
was all heart related went back to the
hospital
was there again for a couple weeks
and then finally I was like man uh
I think I'm gonna die I really felt like
I wasn't gonna die it was so bad I
couldn't lay down you know at all I had
to stay be propped up if I laid down I
couldn't breathe and I was constantly
breathing just like this like
you know and and I wasn't getting enough
oxygen and my heart was my chest was
constantly in pain and it was the most
miserable I had ever been in my life
physically and I felt you know so
destroyed and you know because I looked
around and I saw the other inmates you
know and they're laughing and playing
you know doing this you know it's just
like I couldn't even move I couldn't
even get up and I realized you know what
Freddy man you did this to yourself you
know and it's one thing to be sick
you know um
but it's another thing to know that
you're sick because of your actions I
was like that because of me because of a
lifestyle I chose you know and then I
remembered
this old Bible story and I I didn't know
it that good but I I did remember that
uh you know it was a king and uh you
know some Prophet went to him and told
him your time's up you're gonna die you
know so get your Affairs in order and um
and the King rather than go through the
prophet said
I'm going to talk to God myself and went
to the temple and asked God for more
time
and God gave him 15 more years and uh
and the prophet was all mad you know
like why didn't he die you know
um
I remember that story you know
and um
I thought you know I need to talk to God
and I went up these this little
staircase you know like where the
showers were you know like
uh uh and I made it up there so I could
be by myself
and I
you know got down on my knees as best I
could I said God you know
I'm not gonna make any promises to you
I'm not gonna say if if you do this I'll
be good or I'll quit you know like
because every promise I've ever made
I've broken and and I can't keep any
promise at all all I'm asking
is for a little more time so that I
won't die here in this smelly wretched
County Jail of miserable failure
just I pray that you give me a little
more time so that I could be a good
example to my sons so that I can you
know
um have one more chance at you know at
life you know
so you know uh the next morning I had a
heart attack
so to me I it could have been you know
like request denied stamp you know
um
but something was different because on
my way to the hospital in the ambulance
you know they're they're giving me that
nitroglycerin setting up you know the uh
uh you know the IVs and all this stuff
and I all three times I went to the
hospital in the ambulance I had the same
Hospital driver
and he's right there telling me you know
what
he goes if anybody deserves to go to to
the hospital from the county jail
because a lot of people fake sickness
and go over there and get the good food
at the hospital he goes it's you you
really are sick you know and I was like
dude
I'll tell you what being cool to me
when I get out you go to shamrock tattoo
and I'm gonna give you a free tattoo
and when I said that I felt completely
different like something
the whole time I thought I was gonna die
I was just waiting to die but now I felt
like I'm gonna live I'm I'm gonna I'm
gonna survive I'm gonna live and when I
went to the doctor you know the hospital
it was kind of the same routine
you know they they uh added the meds I
was taking like 14 meds at the time uh I
was there for like
two weeks with the doctor saying you're
really getting we're going to send you
back to the jail you know I went back to
the jail
Austin I started feeling better
I could lay down and sleep so it was
like the meds were really working you
know and then I you know I was even I
even started doing push-ups you know I
was going to the yard like I could walk
around you know it's just like wow I'm
getting better you know and so every
every Tuesday they would take me you
know back to the hospital and then they
checked me so after the third week I was
telling the doctor yeah you know so when
I was doing push-ups he goes push-ups he
goes you do push-ups and I'm like yeah
he goes how many push-ups do I go well I
started with five
but you know I could do 50 right now you
know because let me see you do a couple
push-ups you know and I did some
push-ups he goes okay Sam he goes
this is really odd he goes I'm gonna
have you come back and we're gonna do
the uh
and we're gonna do the echogram and
we're gonna do all those things over
again and check you you know uh you know
there's a this thing where they shoot a
needle some some dye in your veins they
check your heart like that so
um you know I went back did all those
tests and then the next week when I went
back there was like a handful of doctors
right there you know and they're all
listed taking turns listening to my
heart looking at charts and stuff like
that then they all left and just my
doctor was right there and he goes yeah
yeah you know he goes you know most of
us uh we've all heard of things like
this taking place but none of us have
ever seen it you know he goes let me
show you now they want to show you know
they never tell you nothing you know if
they were going to tell me anything
before it was just I can't I don't one
doctor told me I don't see I can go on
without a transplant you know so and he
goes look at your heart
was like this and it was beating
erratically
you know and uh and you your body wasn't
getting any oxygen and your liver was in
failure and your lungs were in failure
and uh your heart was beating at under
10 percent
he goes now
your heart has gone down
and it's beating at 30 percent and 30 to
70 percent is normal you know and um
so for me that was my miracle
that was my miracle from God uh anybody
you know they could tell me whatever you
know like it was this that and you're
saying yeah yeah but to me
my prayer was answered you know and I
was given more time
so
uh what was I gonna do with this new
time you know
um I still have you know this is uh
this was when I was 50 you know and I'm
66 now you know and um
you know
God gave me a new life
and it hasn't been easy
it hasn't been easy I have two sons that
I love I love them more than anything in
the world
and uh and my youngest son you know uh
was murdered you know uh he got shot and
was murdered and um
that was the the worst single event in
my life up to that point
because I was my baby boy man I loved
him so much you know
and um
you know
but I thought I got a I can't give up
I can't fall apart I can't
be a loser I had to fight I have another
son
and uh me and my son Isaiah were very
close
we were so close because we did
everything together I did everything
with my sons together they both live
with me
but Isaiah and I and I lived together he
was a tattoo artist you know we did
shows together we did events together
and you know when I lost my youngest son
you could say I was uh
I I smothered him you know it's like all
my life I I felt like I had courage I've
always been courageous yeah you want to
fight this girl I'm not scared nothing
you know like
and I
I realized
uh when my son passed that nah I'm a
coward
I have great fear because I have fear
that someone I love
will pass or something bad can happen to
someone I love the greatest fear in my
whole life you know and you have your
kids and you raise your kids and you're
trying to protect them and you're always
worried that something's going to happen
to them and when something does it's so
devastating I feel so bad for everybody
that knows what I'm talking about that
has lost a child it's yeah you know it's
the same when you lose a parent and you
lose a loved one but when you lose a
child there's something something there
so I smothered my son Isaiah I was so
afraid of of losing him I did my best to
make money I bought him whatever he he
wanted you know I like
you know um
I had this great fear you know that
something would happen you know and uh
and one day he he was in his room
you know for a couple days and you know
I knew that from time to time he would
you know do drugs do cocaine or speed
and he would isolate himself you know
and uh you know and I tried texting him
and calling him
and then um
I got the knife and I opened up his room
door and my son was dead on the floor
you know
and man
just
what a
over the time you know I lost my first
son
now my first born son
that I was so close to it and
I lost my life
I I I couldn't see living life anymore
you know I just how could I continue on
my both sons are dead you know
and uh
so I had to fight I had to fight
and you know thanks to you know
um people I work with and you know uh my
daughter Elizabeth
you know my grandson Vinnie they were
there for me in the most amazing way
they wouldn't leave me alone
you know I was stuck in that apartment I
didn't want to go anywhere or do
anything
and then uh I met my amazing girl
Deja Garcia she's
she brought new life to me as well so
all these things
you know um
that support
helped me to realize that I still have a
life that I still had to live and I want
to live that life
in a way that would make my sons proud
if they were looking down on me that
they would say
good job dad you're doing good
most of all you know
um
I have to give all the credit to God you
know because you know when I finally did
get sober you know after I had the heart
attacks and all that stuff I did it
through AAA and that's an amazing
program uh AA is uh
you know it's a
tried and proven program and so much so
that that judges will sentence drunk
drivers to AAA classes you know what I
mean but it's a spiritual program and
what I really liked about that you know
like about AAA is that
you know it um
it's God as you understand them they're
not right there saying this is the
religion this is the god this is the way
no it could be
you know the you know if you're Muslim
it could be Allah if you're Buddhist it
could be Buddha or whatever Christ Jesus
whatever it's like as long as you
acknowledge that there is a power
greater than yourselves and that's what
we have to see you know it's but not
only just addicts just as a people right
now everybody hates them each other
right now there's so much violence and
there's no spiritual aspect to life you
know because we can't see that there's a
power greater than us one that we can
believe in one that we can have hope you
know for a better life through this
power you know and and uh
so AAA and that approach because it may
be just
forget about everything
and focus on this higher power and I was
seeing it in every aspect of my life
you know and um
you know and that higher power is what
brought me through the most
uh the worst time the worst thing you
know how could I have survived that I
should have just went right back on
drugs and killed myself you know I
didn't even want to live you know but
that higher power just gave me the drive
to go gave me the power gave me what I
needed and what I really needed
because I I made a full circle I'm not
one I'm not one to preach to anybody to
preach anything but I do have to say
this that when I was in the program with
my higher power I felt like it was
guiding me places and through things and
and um
and I realized that you know what I
really need but I really needed was
Redemption you know because
I've hurt people I've been the I've
worked lived the worst life that anybody
could live I've shot people I've you
know uh
I've never been faithful in a
relationship I'm wretched you know and
um that's why I mean I came back full
circle and I realized that you know what
the the
realest part of God for me is that
sacrifice that Jesus made it for me for
my life for my Redemption and I just say
that as a personal faith I would never
tell anybody that that's what you had to
do I don't go to church I'm not a
born-again I'm not none of that I'm just
a guy that believes in God
and has found Redemption through Jesus
Christ and
it's uh you know a new life for me you
know awesome great talk thank you
Freddie